are you afraid of haunted houses what
about haunted castles or prisons or
mental asylums we've all seen or heard
tales of terrible tortured souls walking
down long and lonely hallways looking
for people to pass their ancient pain
onto but what about something a lot more
subtle perhaps as humble and unassuming
as a cozy little woodshed an adventurer
named kate would find that sometimes
terrible things hide in simple places
with every step twigs broke under the
sole of her boot their snaps echoing
around the emptiness of the surrounding
forest birds caught down at her from
their perches up above a grave omen a
warning not to tread further well at
least to anyone who actually bought into
all that superstitious stuff cat was far
from a believer in that sort of thing
although at the same time she had more
than a passing interest in all things
occult and unnatural for her it was less
about the actual practice of certain
things the appeal was more about the
stories that those practices inspired
legends and myths spooky tales of ghosts
or the dead rising from their graves and
of course the magical mother of them all
witchcraft although her fascination with
the inexplicable and macabre rarely if
ever overlapped with her other big
passion
hiking until of course today she could
trek anywhere and wanted to aim for
everywhere through sprawling national
parks filled with vibrant greenery up
the sides of mountains climbing up to
the peaks to across deserts following
the almost empty highways to get from
one tiny rural town to the next there
was something about getting to not just
know about the world but to actively go
and see it with our own two eyes to
actually be out there in it that felt so
right on her current journey kate had
taken herself on a long trail through
the heart of the american midwest
bugging a heavy pack over her shoulders
filled with her tent sleeping bag
outdoor cooking supplies and all manner
of camping gear she had set off
following the winding path of the patoka
river which ran around or adjacent to a
few of the major cities in the state of
indiana kate was hoping to follow the
flow of its main body of water all the
way through to the city of jasper from
there it would be a straight shot over
to the similarly named patoka lake and
after she had walked around the entire
circumference of that it would be a long
hike east towards west virginia home of
the blue ridge mountains sure it was one
hell of an ambitious trip for one person
traveling alone but kate liked to keep
her journeys unencumbered having someone
else coming with her would just slow her
down or they wouldn't be able to keep up
with her at all there's no fun at all in
that stopping for the night kate lit
herself a campfire she had to make sure
to keep it far enough from the trees to
avoid starting any potential
catastrophes but also not too close to
the wet bank of the patoka otherwise her
kindling wouldn't catch a light there
were so many variables to consider for
any aspiring camper sparks from the
flint that she always took on her
travels struck the dry twig she had
collected and soon a gentle orange glow
and wave of low heat were radiating from
it the fire provided kate with just
enough light to unfold and peg down her
tent as the diminishing visibility of
the dust gave way to the encroaching
nighttime darkness before getting
comfortable in her sleeping bag she put
out her campfire using water from the
patoka then zipped up the front of her
tent keeping a flimsy cloth barrier
between herself and the local wildlife
not everyone found it easy to sleep in
the woods as kate did she couldn't
remember a time when the noise of
breaking twigs or the sounds of movement
outside had ever kept her awake even now
the rustle of leaves and branches did
little to disturb her regardless of
whether it was just the wind or
something else moving through the bushes
woken up by the sun rising its warm
light breaking through the trees kate
readied herself to leave she never
stopped at the same place for more than
one night and rarely slept for any
longer than she needed to a nice
eight-hour recharge of her energy
reserves and then it was back to the
open road after a quick breakfast she
packed up her single-person campsite
folded up her tent and stuffed it back
into her bag kate had been just about to
leave when she noticed something was
missing her compass it had been in her
backpack which she kept in the tent with
her all night quickly scanning the
ground around her she couldn't see it
weird but she figured she had obviously
dropped it at some point during her hike
and would have to pick up a new one when
she got to jasper it didn't matter she
could just follow the patoka river as
planned although it didn't quite sit
easy with her the rest of the day's trek
she'd packed the compass that she was
absolutely certain of after all she knew
it wasn't like her to leave it behind
but then again had she
could she have forgotten it entirely
over the next few hours the question
went round and round in kate's head as
she walked along the bank of the river
silently starting to doubt herself she
drifted a little deeper into the woods
until out of the corner of her eye she
spotted something standing among the
trees it wasn't an animal or even a
figure but a structure spending so much
time out in nature anything man-made
usually stuck out as an obvious
unignorable eye sort of kate she looked
at it from a distance it looked like an
old house isolated out in the woods a
short walk from the patoka river
checking the sky over her shoulder kate
noticed it was getting late again the
daylight having gradually lowered while
she had been wondering about why she had
left her compass behind or if it had
been taken deciding to set up camp
closer to the little house she turned
and headed in to inspect it closer the
place was far from the lap of modern
luxury not that kate couldn't live
without running water or electricity for
long stints of time but it wasn't a
house that had been built recently
although she was no expert in either
archaeology or architecture kate didn't
think anyone had lived there for decades
possibly even centuries it was almost
medieval a single room that was
completely ramshackle practically
falling apart at the seams everywhere
she looked the wood that had originally
been used to build it was either rotting
away or had been broken into splintered
remains plants from the forest had
started growing through the floors and
the walls as if nature was trying to
reclaim this spot of land where someone
had once come to get away from the rest
of the world sighing kat shook her head
as she looked at the dilapidated house
there was no way even she could sleep
there it was too much of a safety risk
parts of the ceiling could easily fall
on her during the night if the wind
picked up enough turning to leave she
stopped in her tracks as she noticed
another structure much smaller behind
the house it had been so dwarfed in size
by the slightly bigger building that it
was completely obscured from view but it
looked to be in much better shape in
terms of its structural integrity it was
a woodshed its front door hanging lazily
open while not exactly brand new by
anyone's standards it was at least far
more intact than the main house taking a
few steps forward kate felt something
like glass crunch under the heel of her
boot she scanned the floor instinctively
checking for any more so as to not
injure herself even with the low amount
of sunlight fading ever rapidly it
didn't look like more kicking her boot
to loosen the shard she made her way
towards the woodshed not noticing that
what she'd been standing on had been a
compass reaching the shed she peered
inside it was pitch black within almost
as dark as the rest of the force would
be in a few minutes taking off her
backpack and setting it down she
searched inside for her flashlight
retrieving it and flipping on the switch
she looked back into the shed and that
was when she saw it taking a step back
cat tripped over her bag scrambling back
up to her feet to make sure she had seen
what she thought she had it was just
lying there still and lifeless for a
split second she hoped it was a trick of
the light just an old decaying lump of
wood but it wasn't it was a body the
remains were charred reduced to little
more than bones some time ago even the
ground next to it looked like it had
been scorched blackened by some intense
fire damage kate's eyes were so
transfixed on the burned mass of bones
that a sudden sound startled her thunder
growled above immediately telling her
she had little choice in what to do next
her options were either she could sleep
outdoors and get drenched by the rain
and possibly catch hypothermia from
being cold and wet or she could spend a
night in the cramped confines of this
woodshed which she would have to share
with a long dead body walking back
outside to retrieve her bag she pulled
out a ground sheet and used it to cover
up the bones it was a mostly sleepless
night and those were a rarity for kate
any sleep she did get was light easily
interrupted by as little as her own
movements and offered her no actual rest
but for the next few hours she just lay
awake on the wooden floor it wasn't the
sounds of rain drumming against the shed
ceiling or the booming of thunderclaps
that were keeping her awake thoughts of
what she was going to do about the bones
kept coming to the forefront of kate's
mind should she report it to the police
when she got to jasper was there even
any point if she had no idea where on
the map this abandoned place was
frustrated she tossed and turned
eventually sitting up as something made
a sound it was a low creaking rusty
metal hinge screeching for a lack of any
oiling over the years the door was open
swinging lazily in the decreasing winds
its lock having long since broken
grumbling to herself kate reached for an
old shovel that had been left in the
shed and went to grab the open door as
her head poked out from the shed she
looked around it was the middle of the
night nothing to be seen anywhere around
yet she couldn't escape the feeling she
was being watched taking the shovel she
damned it underneath the door frame
keeping it closed at last there was
quiet maybe now she'd be able to get
some much-needed sleep and she did but
that's when the nightmare started the
dream was bizarre unlike anything kate
had ever experienced before she
instantly recognized the warm flickering
orange glow of a large fire before her
naturally she started to pace her way
towards it the fire's heat washing over
her the closer she got but as she
approached kade noticed something moving
amongst the flames arms flailed trying
desperately to extinguish the blaze legs
kicking and writhing and that was on top
of the screaming another figure was
standing facing the bonfire their back
to kate as she walked closer still with
every step the sounds of insects buzzing
could be heard getting louder and louder
but it wasn't until she stepped near
enough that she saw where the noise was
coming from a swarm of bugs was darting
through the air hovering around the
other figure there were enough of the
insects that they formed what looked
like a cloak every part of it moving and
buzzing of its own accord the whole
nightmare was so vivid kate had no idea
if it had been brought on by her
exhaustion or that her mind was still
fixated on the bones she'd found in the
woodshed dehydration lack of food or
even some other influence it could have
been any one of those factors that had
caused her to dream a dream like this or
a combination of all of them nonetheless
she could feel the bugs tapping at her
skin as she walked up to the other
figure still unable to see them clearly
the noise of insect wings whizzed past
her ears louder than ever loud enough to
be real putting a hand on the figure's
shoulder kate turned them around it was
a woman or what was left of her she had
huge gaping wounds left by something
that had been cruelly buried in her face
yet somehow she was still standing dead
but also alive at the same time the
swarm of bugs around her moved with her
body as she turned and faced kate a pair
of glassy eyes staring at her they were
both blank completely empty each one
missing its pupil opening her mouth the
woman let out a piercing blood-curdling
shriek all around her the sound of the
bugs got louder almost deafening and as
she screamed so did kate panting and
shuddering she bolted upright shock
racking her entire body hard thudding
against her rib cage instantly the exact
moment she woke up kate realized that
feeling was back she had spent so much
of her time hiking through the woods on
her own that she could tell when someone
was watching her in the dark she fumbled
for her flashlight and clicked it on to
reveal the door was still jammed shut
apart from her there was no one else
inside the shed no one alive at least
looking over her shoulder she could see
the bones behind her and immediately
backed away from them as far as she
could in that tiny wooden hut she had
covered them before going to bed she was
certain of it hadn't she all of a sudden
kate felt her skin start to itch an
intense irritating feeling she had
experienced the effects of poison ivy
and all sorts of plants that caused
similar reactions but this was easily a
thousand times worse her skin felt like
it was burning she scraped her
fingernails down her exposed arm trying
to suppress the itching even for a
moment but it did nothing she scratched
at the other arm over and over again in
one spot until her flesh was pink and
raw still no change kate raked her nails
over her own body this time leaving a
deep scratch trailing over her arm under
the light of her torch she'd realized
that she'd drawn blood she looked back
at the bones in the scorch corner of the
shed the skull was facing straight
towards her hollowed out eye sockets
staring as empty as the pupils eyes of
the woman in her nightmare it had done
this it must have done she thought
reaching towards the door dropping her
flashlight she wrenched the shovel out
from where she used it to wedge the
entrance closed she stood up kicking her
sleeping bag and backpack to the side as
hard as she could desperate to make the
itching stop kate brought the shovel
downwards the head of it snapped the
already weakened floorboards of the shed
exposing the soft dry earth beneath
maybe if she buried those charred
remains whatever was happening to her
would stop frantically she started
digging hurling shovelfuls of dirt
through the shed door it listed further
open creaking loudly on its rusted
hinges again causing cape to turn
startled at the sound of it knocking
against the outer wall of the shed
someone was looking right at her she
could feel it as real and as persistent
as the itching feeling that crawled over
her skin like the tiny legs of an army
of insects she dug further eventually
throwing the shovel to one side and
dragging her hands through the exposed
earth below desperately burrowing
through and only stopping to use any
rock she found to try and stop the itch
all she achieved was drawing more blood
her fingers touched something soft but
solid and kate brushed away to clear
more of the excess dirt trying to
uncover whatever it was it felt like a
long mass just beneath the ground with a
second similar object parallel to it but
the further along with it she reached
the quicker she realized what it was the
leg clearing more of the dirt higher up
kate could feel more a stomach ribs
shoulders and a head reaching for her
flashlight buried under some of the dirt
that had been dug up she pointed it at
the thing she'd found the woman the same
one from her nightmare
something inside her chest moved
scratching sharply causing kate to cough
and once she started she couldn't stop
it was like the itching she felt on the
outside had now worked its way inside
and it was spreading no moving in fact
not just moving but crawling through her
lungs burrowing down into her stomach
and at the same time
upwards the clawing of tiny legs digging
their way up her windpipe blocking it
kate couldn't breathe she dropped to her
knees wretching as she struggled for air
sputtering as she felt something move at
the back of her throat that was when she
heard the buzzing again locusts a swarm
of them came spilling out of kate's
mouth she couldn't scream let alone
catch her breath they filled the shed in
seconds engulfing her entire body as
more and more of the desert bugs still
came pouring from her mouth outside the
wind kicked up again with enough force
to blow the door to the woodshed closed
trapping kate inside with the bugs that
tore at her there was a single word on
the wooden surface of the door written
in deep black charcoal she'd missed it
the door had been opened when she found
the shed the word was which the scp
foundation would later find this cursed
cabin and would naturally lose a number
of d-classes to a horrific form of
locust-based suffocation well there are
clues as to what exactly is going on in
this terrible place from the malice of a
long dead sorceress to the lingering
revenge of a woman wrongfully persecuted
definite answers as to the anomalous
mechanisms of the shed known as scp-4595
still elude even the foundation's finest
minds it's a place so mysterious and
dangerous that the special containment
procedures read for safety purposes no
personnel are permitted to enter
scp-4595
scp-4595 should only be entered by
authorized testing personnel under the
supervision of the scp-4595
research lead under no circumstances is
scp-4595-a to be disturbed in any way so
perhaps we'll never truly know why a
humble wooden shed in jasper indiana
causes such horrifying effects for its
victims the scp foundation thinks it's
safer to just lock it away and forget
about it letting its ancient wood and
old bones rot in the dark but if you are
really curious about the truth you can
always take a walk down the side of the
patoka river and pay the witch a visit
if you're lucky you might even get to
leave now go and check out scp-4000
taboo and
scp-3333 tower to learn more about some
strange landmarks and places that it's
best to avoid next time you go hiking
through the woods on your own